Traductor: Sebastian Betti
Revisor: Ana Santos
Las papas fritas son deliciosas.
Y las papas fritas con kétchup
son un pedacito del paraíso.
El problema es
que es casi imposible
verter la cantidad justa.
Estamos tan acostumbrados a poner
kétchup que no notamos
lo extraño de su comportamiento.
Imagina una botella de kétchup
llena de acero.
Por más que la agites,
el acero no saldrá.
Ahora imagina una botella
llena de agua.
Saldrá fácilmente.
El kétchup, sin embargo,
no se decide.
¿Es un sólido?
¿O un líquido?
La respuesta es: depende.
Los fluidos más comunes como el agua,
los aceites y los alcoholes,
responden linealmente a la fuerza.
Si uno los presiona 2 veces más fuerte,
se mueven 2 veces más rápido.
Sir Isaac Newton, conocido por su manzana,
fue el primero en sugerir esta relación
por eso estos fluidos
se denominan newtonianos.
El kétchup, no obstante, es parte
de un grupo de infractores lineales
llamados fluidos no newtonianos.
La mayonesa, la pasta de dientes, la sangre,
la pintura, la mantequilla de maní
y muchos otros fluidos responden
a la fuerza de manera no lineal.
Es decir, cambian su viscosidad aparente
en función de lo fuerte que presiones,
o cuánto tiempo, o qué tan rápido.
Y el kétchup es no newtoniano
por partida doble.
Primero, cuanto más duro uno presiona,
menos parece salir.
Por debajo de una cierta fuerza,
se comporta como un sólido.
Pero una vez pasado
ese punto de inflexión,
cambia y se vuelve mil veces
menos viscoso que antes.
Suena familiar, ¿no?
Segundo, si uno presiona con
una fuerza menor al umbral
al final, empezará a fluir.
En este caso el tiempo, no la fuerza,
es la clave para liberar el kétchup
de su prisión de vidrio.
Muy bien, pero, ¿por qué se comporta
de forma tan extraña?
Bueno, está hecho a base de tomates
pulverizados, aplastados, golpeados,
completamente destruidos.
¿Ves estas diminutas partículas?
Esto es lo que queda de
las células del tomate
luego del tratamiento que
lo transforma en kétchup.
¿Y el líquido circundante?
Es principalmente agua, algo
de vinagre, azúcar y especias.
Cuando el kétchup está en reposo,
las partículas de tomate se distribuyen
de manera uniforme y aleatoriamente.
Ahora, supongamos que aplicas
poca fuerza muy rápido.
Las partículas se golpean mutuamente,
pero no pueden quitarse del camino,
por eso el kétchup no fluye.
Ahora, supongamos que aplicas una
fuerza potente, muy rápidamente.
Esa fuerza adicional es suficiente
para aplastar las partículas de tomate
y quizá en vez de esferitas
se forman pequeñas
elipses y, ¡buum!
Ahora hay espacio suficiente
para que algunas partículas
pasen sobre otras
y fluya el kétchup.
Ahora supongamos que aplicas una fuerza
muy débil pero durante mucho tiempo.
Resulta que no estamos muy seguros
de lo que pasa en este escenario.
Una posibilidad es que las partículas
que están en las paredes del contenedor
lentamente vayan hacia el medio,
dejando la sopa en
la que están disueltas,
que recuerden, básicamente es agua,
cerca del borde.
Esa agua sirve como lubricante
entre la botella de vidrio
y el tapón de kétchup del centro,
y entonces fluye el kétchup.
Otra posibilidad es que las partículas
lentamente se reacomoden
en pequeños grupos, que luego
fluyen unos sobre otros.
Los científicos que estudian fluidos
siguen investigando activamente
la dinámica del kétchup
y sus buenos compañeros.
El kétchup se hace menos viscoso
cuanto más lo presionas,
pero otras sustancias, como la masilla
o algunas mantequillas naturales de maní,
se hacen más viscosas
cuanto uno más las presiona.
Otras sustancias
pueden subir rotando,
o seguir saliendo
una vez que empezaron a hacerlo.
Sin embargo, desde una
perspectiva física,
el kétchup es una de las mezclas
más complicadas que hay.
Y, como si eso no fuera suficiente,
el equilibrio de ingredientes
y la presencia de espesantes
naturales como la goma de xantano,
que también se encuentra en
muchas bebidas frutales y batidos,
pueden hacer que
2 kétchup distintos
se comporten de formas
totalmente diferentes.
Pero ambos mostrarán
2 propiedades distintivas:
repentina disminución de la viscosidad
ante una fuerza umbral,
y una disminución más gradual
al aplicar una pequeña fuerza
durante un largo
período de tiempo.
Y eso implica que puede extraerse
el kétchup de 2 maneras:
o bien se lo agita en series
largas, lentas y lánguidas
asegurándose de nunca
dejar de aplicar fuerza,
o bien puedes golpear la botella
una vez, con mucha, mucha energía.
Los que saben dejan la tapa puesta,
sacuden la botella con fuerza, un instante,
para despertar a las partículas de tomate,
luego sacan la tapa
y vierten el kétchup de manera controlada
sobre sus celestiales papas.